C'est vraiment la nature
qui reprend ses droits,
la biodiversité qui est là, quoi !
Là, on a une belle vitrine
de ce qu'il peut se passer
quand on fait un peu
attention à sa terre.
Bonjour, moi, c'est Laura Calu,
je suis humoriste.
Et aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de vous faire
découvrir mon village natal
qui est dans le Var,
qui s'appelle Correns, qui est très joli
mais qui est surtout le premier
village entièrement biologique de France.
C'est en 1997 officiellement
que le village est passé
en agriculture
entièrement biologique.
C'est-à-dire que tous les producteurs,
les viticulteurs,
se sont mis à faire du bio
donc à transformer leurs terres, à ne plus
utiliser de produits chimiques.
Et le village est,
depuis un moment maintenant,
le premier village bio de France
donc c'est quand même une fierté.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
un petit peu ce que vous faites
exactement comme travail ?
- Alors nous, avec Dune,
on fait vraiment
tout ce qui est travail du sol.
Là, c'est le printemps,
on va nettoyer les pieds des vignes
pour ne pas qu'elles se fassent gagner
par l'herbe ni que ça amène des maladies.
Ok, on va faire un premier tour comme ça.
Et tu vois, après, là, je peux régler
la profondeur de mon outil.
- D'accord.
- Pour régler à quelle profondeur
je veux travailler.
Et vraiment, avec elle, je peux aller
soit collé au rang, soit me mettre au milieu,
vraiment, faire de la haute couture
de la vigne quoi.
Ce qui est génial aussi,
pour moi tu vois,
c'est la relation
qu'on a à travailler ensemble,
c'est vraiment ma collègue de travail.
- Elle est plus sympa
que Justine de la compta.
Alors un cheval, qu'est-ce que
ça change d'un tracteur ?
- Ça va vraiment se passer
dans la vie du sol.
Dune, elle va beaucoup moins
tasser qu'un tracteur,
elle va pouvoir travailler
vraiment plus précisément
au pied de la vigne.
Et zéro pesticide, voilà.
Être dans la vraie démarche.
- Ça fonctionne au foin ?
- Au bio, foin bio !
- Et vous, vous êtes bio ?
- À fond !
- Vos enfants sont bio ?
On est des bio-man !
Donc là, c'est la plante responsable de mes
plus durs lendemains de soirées, c'est ça ?
Pour toi, quelle est la différence
entre le bio et le non bio ?
- En viticulture je parle ?
- Ouais.
- C'est le travail du sol, c'est-à-dire que nous,
on n'a plus de désherbant chimique,
c'est tout mécanique, on va dire.
Nous, on n'emploie pas de désherbant chimique
et on travaille notre sol.
Alors après, il faut accepter en bio
d'avoir un peu d'herbe.
C'est sûr que l'herbe, à cette époque-là,
fait une concurrence à la vigne.
Mais quand elle est maîtrisée
et gérée comme ça,
ça ne pose aucun problème.
- Pourquoi t'es fier de faire du bio ?
Pourquoi c'est important ?
- Pourquoi ? Parce que déjà,
on ne s'intoxique pas nous, utilisateurs.
On préserve notre nature
pour les générations futures
et ça, je pense que
c'est le plus important.
Et après, j'avoue que quand
on sait les produits qu'on applique
et quand on sait, dans la bouteille, ce qu'il y a,
je trouve ça génial pour le client.
C'est de dire : en plus on fait
un effort pour la planète
et en plus, on ne vous intoxique pas
avec des produits chimiques.
- On va sauver la planète !
- Ah ça ! Je ne sais pas
si on va sauver la planète !
Là, tu as toute la beauté du village...
- Ça, ça s'appelle une calade.
On n'emploie pas de désherbant,
bien entendu.
Et un peu d'herbe n'a jamais
fait de tort à quelqu'un...
Ça ne sert à rien
que ce soit trop propre.
- Quand est-ce que ça a commencé
à Correns, le bio ? Et pourquoi ?
- Tu es née en quelle année, toi ?
- En 1990 !
- Pour fêter tes 5 ans,
donc en 1995,
tous les paysans de Correns
ont décidé de passer en bio
et disons que c'est
la première fois en France
que tout un village est en agriculture bio
et depuis plus de 20 ans.
À une époque où
personne n'y croyait
et tous les villages du coin
rigolaient de nous.
J'ai été très sensibilisé au problème
des phytosanitaires
et au problème des OGM.
Et je me suis rendu compte
que les puissances de l'argent
décidaient notre avenir sans que
ça nous appartienne démocratiquement.
Et donc, je trouve qu'il y a vraiment
un très, très gros problème philosophique.
Et donc la seule façon
de réagir à ça,
c'est de ne pas rentrer
dans leur système d'agrobusiness
et c'est de prendre
d'autres voies agricoles
qui respectent le monde, qui respectent
nos enfants et nos petits-enfants.
On a également travaillé
sur la cantine
et donc, depuis une dizaine d'années,
on est à peu près à
75 % à 80 % bio à la cantine.
Avant chaque début de repas, on explique
aux enfants ce qu'ils vont manger,
d'où vient la courgette,
on fait des repas végétariens...
Il y a une très forte pédagogie.
Les enfants apprennent
à manger de tout
et on voit que la courbe
de gaspillage est très basse.
À Correns, on jette moins de 10 %.
Au niveau national, on jette 30 %.
Et le truc dont je suis le plus fier,
c'est qu'aux réunions de parents d'élèves,
les parents me disent : "Maintenant,
le soir, on est obligés de cuisiner."
- La maison où j'ai grandi !
- Où ça ?
- Ici, les toilettes, voilà.
Donc c'est là que j'ai fait
mes premiers pipis... bio !
Parce que je consommais bio !
- Donc ça, c'est le jardin partagé.
Donc il y a une dizaine ou une quinzaine
de personnes qui ont des petits morceaux,
qui cultivent soit des fleurs
soit des légumes.
- Et ils doivent respecter
l'agriculture biologique ?
- Évidemment, ils respectent
l'agriculture biologique,
ils compostent ensemble...
- Et du coup, le partage à Correns,
quand les gens partagent les terres,
quand ils ont à leur disposition
un potager, c'est gratuit ?
- Cet espace, qui est à peu près
de 1500 m2,
est mis gratuitement
à disposition des gens
parce qu'on estime que les gens
qui vivent dans le village
n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir des jardins
donc on leur met gratuitement ça.
- C'est trop bon.
- Il y a 25 ans, tout le monde
rigolait des Corrensois
et maintenant, tout le monde
vient voir l'exemple ici.
Donc je pense que c'est
en train de prendre
et je pense que les gens ont beaucoup de respect
du choix courageux qui a été fait ici.
Il y a un rajeunissement des agriculteurs
d'une façon impressionnante.
La moyenne d'âge des paysans
à Correns, c'est 35-40 ans.
Dans le Var, c'est 55-60.
Donc ici, il y a vraiment une nouvelle génération
de paysans qui sont arrivés,
qui ont une agriculture
très moderne, mécanisée
mais qui ont comme principe de faire tout
pour respecter la nature.
Parce que c'est ça la philosophie du bio,
ce n'est pas d'être dans
une agriculture passéiste,
c'est au contraire,
c'est l'agriculture de demain.
Qu'est-ce qu'on entend, là,
Léa ?
- Mes poules !
- Tes poules ?
- Petites poules pondeuses.
Donc moi, je fais des œufs
et des poulets.
Donc ça, ce sont mes petites pondeuses
qui font des œufs, forcément.
- Nourries au bio ?
- Nourries en bio,
terrain bio, poules bio...
Là, ils sont en semi-liberté, on va dire,
avec des grands parcs.
Donc ça change des cages en industriel.
- Alors, comment tu les nourris
tes poulets, Léa ?
- Alors, depuis peu en plus, j'ai fait
un groupement avec d'autres éleveurs
et on fabrique notre propre grain
en achetant à des céréaliers du coin.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- Donc ça, c'est l'aliment de mes poules.
Donc là, en ce moment,
il y a du maïs, de l'orge,
du soja, du tourteau de sésame...
- Ça a l'air meilleur que ce que
je mets dans le lait le matin !
- ... de la féverole aussi, voilà.
- On peut parler
ou comment ça se passe ?
Quelle est la différence à faire
du bio et du non-bio ?
- C'est surtout la superficie
des parcs à l'extérieur.
Pour les poulets bio, il faut 4 m2
en extérieur par poulet.
Tandis qu'en industriel,
ils sont généralement en cage,
donc ils ont 80 centimètres, les cages.
En bio, on n'a pas le droit de
les abattre avant au moins 3 mois
donc le poulet moyen, une fois abattu,
on va dire prêt à cuire,
il fait entre 2 kg et 2,5 kg,
voire plus.
C'est toi qui la tiens ?
- Comment je l'attrape ?
- Tu tiens là, les pattes dessous.
- Donc voilà, un vrai poulet bio,
ça ressemble à ça.
Donc déjà, ça a des plumes.
- Ouais, ça a encore des plumes.
- Ce n'est pas tout gras, il y a aussi du...
- Du muscle !
- Voilà, il y a du muscle, ce n'est pas
un truc tout gras qui ne peut pas marcher
avec des pattes tordues, on est d'accord ?
- C'est ça !
Je ne me vois pas enfermer
une poule dans une cage,
c'est tellement plus sympa
quand ça court dehors !
- C'est compliqué de se lancer
dans le bio aujourd'hui ?
- Ça a été compliqué
au niveau des papiers,
ils ne sont pas habitués à avoir
des petits élevages
donc il faut remplir des cases
que je ne remplis pas.
- Tu as l'impression qu'on
n'est pas forcément aidé ?
- Oui, pas aidé du tout.
Ni en tant que jeune, ni en bio, ni rien...
- C'est quand même super grave !
- Quand on commence à mettre les pieds là-dedans,
il faut être très, très, très motivé.
Pour s'installer, il faut bien s'accrocher
et après, ça vaut le coup, ouais.
- D'être là aujourd'hui, de voir tout ça,
ça me donne envie de mieux consommer,
de moins manger de viande, aussi.
Pas parce que je n'ai pas envie
de manger ces poulets,
justement, j'ai envie
de manger cette viande-là.
Les viandes en supermarché,
comme ça, à la chaîne,
les animaux qui ne peuvent même plus
marcher, entassés,
c'est n'importe quoi !
Et donc, quand une nana comme elle,
dans son petit village,
décide de tenir un projet
comme celui-là, jusqu'au bout,
c'est respectable.
Cette petite abeille
porte le nom de Maya...
Comment tu appelles ça ?
- Une combinaison.
- Une combinaison pour se protéger
des abeilles, des piqûres d'abeilles.
- Voilà, des piqûres d'abeilles.
Surtout que les abeilles, elles peuvent
se prendre dans nos cheveux aussi.
Les ruches ici, sur Correns, elles font
principalement du miel de romarin,
voilà et du miel
de bruyère à l'automne.
Tout est bio, alors voilà,
moi, tous mes miels sont bio.
L'agriculture biologique, étant donné
qu'il n'y a pas de désherbage chimique,
c'est super important.
Le désherbement aussi a fait
beaucoup de mal à l'abeille.
Correns, c'est bien parce que le bio,
il oblige à garder
une certaine nature autour de soi.
Et donc du coup, comme
l'abeille vit dans la nature,
plus il y a de nature
et plus elles sont heureuses.
- Même moi, je serais bien là !
Je ferais un super miel.
Alors Julien, qu'est-ce que
tu fais, toi, à Correns ?
- Alors moi, ce que je fais à Correns,
je propose des balades sur la rivière,
donc je fais la location de kayaks
sur l'Argence, c'est un fleuve en fait.
J'utilise les kayaks pour faire découvrir
mon fleuve, mon endroit.
On va se mettre un petit gilet.
- Stylé, non ?
Fashion week ou pas fashion week ?
- Ce qui est super, c'est que moi, qui connais
ce fleuve par cœur, à chaque fois, je redécouvre !
Parce qu'à chaque fois ça vit,
ça change, ça bouge...
- Qu'est-ce que tu as remarqué
en 20 ans de bio en fait,
d'agriculture biologique ? Qu'est-ce que
tu as remarqué comme changements ?
- Il y a eu pas mal de changements
au niveau de la faune et de la flore.
C'est vrai qu'on a vu
une différence assez énorme.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que
comme on est passé en bio,
moi, je vais parler surtout de la rivière,
on s'est intéressé un peu à
ce qui arrivait de plus haut.
Et là, on s'est aperçu,
il y a 20 ans,
qu'il y avait un peu de rejets
qui n'étaient pas très propres.
Donc ça, on l'a fait savoir, il y a eu
un travail très important à ce niveau-là.
Et du coup, on a un fleuve qui arrive
et qui est très propre.
- Donc tu as, aujourd'hui,
plus d'animaux que tu ne voyais plus ?
- Plus d'animaux, exactement.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on voit comme
animaux sur la rivière ?
- Alors on voit, sur la rivière,
en principal les plus beaux,
on va voir les martins-pêcheurs,
ça, c'est magnifique.
On va voir des hérons, des hérons cendrés,
des hérons pourpres.
On va trouver des canards,
des poules d'eau, des ragondins...
- Et des Laura Calu ?
- Et des Laura Calu en plus !
- Je n'aime pas la pollution, moi !
- Ça, c'est un gage de pureté !
On a un martin-pêcheur
qui vient de décoller juste là.
Oh, le héron ! Tu l'as vu ?
Alors là, ces algues, c'est des lentilles d'eau.
Moi, quand j'étais gamin, ici, il y avait
peut-être deux ou trois algues différentes,
on n'en voyait pas tant que ça.
Et là, maintenant on est peut-être à...
il y a facilement une dizaine d'algues différentes.
S'il y avait une seule algue qui colonisait tout,
là, on pourrait commencer à s'inquiéter.
Donc c'est une façon aussi de surveiller
la qualité de l'eau.
Depuis qu'on est passé en bio,
on s'aperçoit quand même d'une différence.
C'est vrai que les pesticides,
les herbicides finissaient dans la rivière.
Donc toutes ces algues n'existaient pas parce qu'elles
étaient tuées par tous ces produits chimiques.
Donc c'est vrai qu'on voit
une réelle différence.
On a un papillon qui avait disparu,
qui est revenu.
- Ah, qui avait disparu, carrément !
- Qui avait complètement disparu !
- On voit une différence : il y a des fleurs
qui avaient complètement disparu aussi,
qui se remettent à pousser.
- Donc que je n'ai pas vues pendant mon enfance ?
- Exactement.
Faire grandir ses enfants dans un environnement
comme ça, c'est quelque chose d'assez magique,
d'assez précieux.
Donc c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de petites
familles qui viennent s'installer
pour que les enfants grandissent
dans ce havre de paix,
son petit coin de paradis où on n'est pas
trop embêté par la pollution,
où on peut manger des choses saines.
Et ça, ça encourage beaucoup de gens, quoi.
- Tu as l'espoir quand tu vis
sur un environnement pareil ?
- Ici, moi, j'en profite justement
pour faire beaucoup d'éducation
parce qu'ici, on a la matière à montrer
que la nature reprend sa place,
elle reprend ses droits.
On l'abîme, ça c'est sûr
mais c'est nous qui allons le payer,
ce n'est pas forcément la nature.
La nature, elle reviendra.
- C'était important, pour moi,
de montrer la rivière de l'Argence
et de faire cette balade en canoë avec Julien.
Et il m'a vraiment fait prendre
conscience de l'évolution du village,
de la forêt, du vert...
Quand on fait cette balade en rivière,
on se rend compte que ça a changé,
énormément, que ça a évolué.
Il y a bien plus de végétation,
il y a beaucoup de poissons,
d'animaux, d'insectes.
Et pourtant, je n'aime pas trop les insectes
mais, ici, je les accepte parce que je me dis :
"Mais non, c'est tellement normal qu'il y ait
des insectes, c'est qu'il y a la vie !"
Quand on voit dans l'eau, toutes ces plantes
vertes... dans l'eau, qui poussent dans l'eau !
Il n'y en avait pas quand j'étais petite, déjà.
En fait, je suis fière de voir tous ces gens,
tous ces habitants du village,
tenir leur engagement
envers la planète.
Ici, ça me donne de l'espoir. Je me dis :
"Mais si, en fait, c'est possible !
Mais en fait, ça marche !
Quand on fait attention à la planète,
il y a vraiment du changement !
Ah mais en fait, on n'est pas foutu !"
Mais ça donne envie toute cette verdure.
Comment tu peux ne pas avoir envie
et en plus si c'est faisable !
Du coup, comment tu peux ne pas te dire :
"J'ai envie de faire ça, moi aussi."
Et ce qui est frappant,
c'est que c'est possible
et ici, ça prouve que ça l'est,
tout simplement.